[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen
gerade jetzt zur garten- und erdbeerzeit
finde ich löffel dass es immer wirklich
perfekt heute habe ich ein sehr
einfaches rezept für euch mit ein paar
wenigen flut haben und zwar gibt ein
erster kuss tiramisu das eignet sich
natürlich perfekt für die nächste
gartenparty oder einfach auch mal so
wenn ihr lust auf erdbeeren habt ich
habe das hier eben einer triple
glasschale geschichte dafür dies
wirklich wunderschön drin wenn ihr so
eine schüssel nicht habt könnt ihr auch
zum beispiel so eine große auflaufform
nehmen ich finde immer ganz schön wenn
tim graf geschichtet wird da es wirklich
wunderbare schöne geschichten mit drin
hat ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten
und dann starten begleichen
für die etwas wofür brauche ich 200
gramm erdbeeren
hier habe ich jeweils 100 milliliter
orangensaft und kokosmilch ihr könnt
auch konflikte verwenden für den brauche
ich jeweils 500 gramm ab ohne und marke
quakt 80 gramm puderzucker etwas vanille
extrakt jeweils 60 gramm kokosraspeln
und weiße schokolade zwei esslöffeln
limettensaft und 200 milliliter sahne
und ich brauch noch 700 vom ersten die
schleifer und 200 gramm löffelbiskuits
ich fange jetzt zuerst einmal mit der
etwas soße am dafür nimmt die erdbeeren
und die flüssigkeiten also wie gesagt
orangensaft und kokosmilch wenn ihr
möchtet kokos liga bringt ein bisschen
merkt mit rein aber dann ist da
überlegen da kann man hat keine kinder
mit essen wird einfach kurz gerät
so bekam dann kurz auf die breite und
dann geht es direkt weiter mit der creme
das hat sich nie mit mascarpone und
quark ihr könnt auch zum beispiel
mascarpone und joghurt nehmen gemacht ab
ohne sorgt dafür dass es schön cremig
wird und der quark oder joghurt dopplung
geführt es ist einfach sehr frisch wird
und nicht so schwer
doch wirklich sehr sehr einfaches rezept
aber alles in einer schüssel rhein rhone
quark etwas vanille extrakt passt sehr
gut zu den erdbeeren der fotograf da
könnt ihr auch butter zucker nach
geschmack zu geben also als die arena
füllt einfach ein bisschen weniger foto
zucker die kugel geht es gleich mit rein
zuerst macht die sahne und dem limetten
was
die zutaten werden jetzt ganz vorsichtig
schon miteinander verrührt hier kommen
jetzt noch die kokosraspeln mit dazu und
weil ich noch die schokolade fein hacken
und auch mit einer mio
sie kennt die schokolade auch gerne
schmelzen und mit dazu geben aber ich
finde wenn sie so ein stückchen mit
dabei ist hat man einfach noch mal so
schön cremig mit dabei davon kurz
umrühren und dann ist die creme auch
schon so weit jetzt noch die erdbahn
geschnitten die könnte jetzt entweder in
würfel schneiden oder entscheiden mit
dem messer oder einfach mit einem
abwasch leider bisher schon schichten
ich hab jetzt etwa zehn minuten
gebraucht also wirklich nur verkürzen
sehr schnell
jetzt kommen zuerst an allah für gott da
könnte jetzt die dicken nehmen oder so
wie ich diese besetzungen und da ist die
besitzungen nehme werde ich sie jetzt
hochkant hinstellen dass sie einfach nur
die geschichte
darüber kommt jetzt eine schicht also
ich werde jetzt insgesamt zwei schichten
machen denke ich
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt eine erdschicht drüber
und stand die creme und dann kommt das
ganze einfach noch mal drauf
[Musik]
ich habe ich alles geschichtet und dafür
ist nur noch die dekade habe ich noch
ein paar erdbeeren minzblätter ein
akustik kokosraspeln weiße schokolade
und in die mitte damit sie einen festen
reiser und nehme jetzt hier limetten
feste ab dann richtig hübsch aus kommt
hier oben drauf
[Musik]
dann kommen ein paar erst beim drauf
und für die schokolade nehme ich jetzt
einem sparschäler und scharf doch kleine
runter jetzt ist das dessert
fertiggestellt ist noch für etwa eine
stunde in den kühlschrank
ihr könnt das auch gerne über nacht in
den kühlschrank stellen und dann kann es
schon saniert werden
aber ich denke natürlich auch an
jetzt ist das sehr sehr gut durch
gekühlt und wir können probieren
murat ist gerade noch mit den kindern
unterwegs mit zwei männer
wir wollten spazieren gehen und auch ein
spielplatz ich weiß es nicht ganz genau
die stellen zusammen immer irgendwas an
werde ich hier einfach rauslassen
am besten einfach wirklich von oben nach
unten und kleinen plätzen
denkt ihr wahrscheinlich warum bei
keller und zwar habe ich meinen bruder
da und wenn die uns schon freuen
und jetzt trifft es probleme lustig noch
abwehren
wenn du dich probieren
mein bruder recht dran mein ist es kein
knoblauch darin kein klobiger hoffe mein
foto verträgt keinen knoblauch und du
musst auch kein hochdeutsch speicher du
kannst auch super freut mich für das
kilo koloss super doch weiße schokolade
schokolade beilegen und erfrischend ich
freue mich dass auch gleich auf meine
passion und falls jetzt auch lust darauf
bekommen habt dann schaut auch fertig -
blog.de vorbei und lademeister 100 druck
das aus oder schaut euch auf eurem handy
an geht einkaufen und probiert auf jeden
fall diese bisher aus ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal noch nachschlag
ja
[Musik]